[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres est-ce que nous sommes en
train d'entrer dans une aire de
glaciation des rapports humains sous
l'effet de la révolution numérique et
incline à l'égoïsme allégotisme même au
narcissisme aux communes notarisme enfin
à tous ces mots barbares
bref est-ce que nous sommes en train
d'aller vers la des liaison sociale
est-ce que nous assistons à la fin de la
sociabilité c'est d'ailleurs le titre
que nous avons donné à cette émission
pour en parler avec nous Daniel Cohen
bonsoir Daniel vous publiez homo
numérique US chez Albin Michel vous êtes
un chercheur en économie très connu et
reconnu vous dirigez vous avez cofondé
l'École de Paris l'économie ou vous
diriger un laboratoire de la rue d'Ulm
le ce Prémat mais là vous sortez de
votre discipline pour prophétiser la
société dans laquelle nous allons et où
le numérique joue un rôle clé et pas
forcément réjouissant
mais avant de parler de cela avec vous
nous allons échanger avec Daniel le
tartakowski bonsoir Daniel et soir vous
vous publiez vous diriger en fait avec
quatre de vos collègues historiens une
histoire de la rue de l'Antiquité à nos
jours chez Talandier donc vous êtes
historienne vous avez enseigné à Paris 8
vous avez présidé le Comité d'histoire
de la ville de Paris
et là vous dirigez cette cette histoire
de la rue pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
choisi tout d'abord comme objet la rue
comme objet d'investigation scientifique
alors le sujet auront César ce qui est à
César l'idée revient à Joël Cornette et
on a réuni des collègues qui avaient
tous touché à la rue de par leur
recherche scientifique mon Catherine
Saliou est une spécialiste de la rue
sous Antioche dans l'Antiquité les
quatre autres à savoir Claude Gauvard
Joël cornette Emmanuel furet c'est
moi-même nous avions tous dans nos
travaux abordés sous un angle quelconque
la rue et on s'est réuni on s'est dit
essayons de non pas juste à poser nos
travaux mais de penser la rue sous
toutes ses approches la rue sous tous
ces angles et finalement en travaillant
c'est moi qui me suis
occupé de la période contemporaine je
suis contemporainiste il y a un retour
de la rue il y a un retour de la rue qui
ne mettait pas appar de façon aussi
nette avant d'engager le travail on va y
revenir alors ce qui frappe tout d'abord
on vous lisant c'est que depuis le cardo
romain jusqu'au grandes avenues
cardo-romain qui était la lus la les
centrale de la de la cité latine
jusqu'au grandes avenues des villes
contemporaines il y a une incroyable
continuité d'ailleurs quand on lit les
Juvénal sur les embarras de Rome puis la
bruyère sur les embarrasses Paris on
n'est pas très loin de la chanson de Joe
Dassin sur les embouteillages donc là la
chose qui frappe d'abord c'est la
continuité historique de la fonction de
la rue alors continuité mais notre
objectif n'est évidemment pas de dire
que rien n'a changé et que tout est
comme avant nous avons essayé de
combiner les phénomènes de longue durée
de quoi sommes-nous les héritiers et
essayer de montrer comment il a trouvé
toute une série de c'est une
rupalamceste comment il y a des strates
qui se sont surimposer les unes aux
autres le plan est plus ou moins
chronologique je dirais mais
les héritages sont multiples et ces
lectures complexes d'une rue creuset
mais également d'une rue
d'une rue quelques fois c'est pas que
nous avons essayé de mettre en évidence
alors d'abord on observe mais ça nous
ramène un autre sujet d'aujourd'hui que
c'est le lieu du la circulation bien sûr
mais c'est le lieu du commerce c'est le
lieu de la promenade c'est le lieu de la
conversation au moins populaire c'est
parfois aussi le lieu de la rixe c'est
le lieu de la barricade et donc c'est le
lieu par excellence de la sociabilité
que cette sociabilité soit positive ou
négative absolument absolument
d'ailleurs la photographie de la
couverture qui est une rue parisienne
montre comment il y a coexistence nous
sommes au tournant du 19e 20e siècle
coexistence toute une série d'acteurs
qui ont l'air de ne pas se déranger les
uns les autres ce qui quelquefois
devient plus complexe
mais il y a tout de même à partir du 19e
siècle une rupture enfin il y a une
série de phénomènes dont l'automobile va
être à la fois
l'aboutissement et en même temps
l'accélérateur il y a l'exode rural il y
a la verticalisation des immeubles il y
a et puis il y a finalement en effet le
la circulation automobile qui vont
rompre un peu cette idée de la
sociabilité
et
séparé les gens plutôt que les
rassembler comme je le disais notre plan
n'est pas tout à fait chronologique il y
a bien sûr l'Antiquité il fallait la
mettre en place puisque nous en sommes
durablement les héritiers mais Claude
Gauvard a eu ensuite l'idée de
construire le livre autour de l'idée
d'un long Moyen-Âge alors selon le
moyen-âge il intègre bien sur l'époque
moderne il intègre une
d'éléments du 19e siècle et je disais
qu'on aurait parfaitement eu pu y
intégrer les lotissements des années 20
qui avait été étudié par anni-fourcaud
donc selon 20e siècle n'est pas mort
dans quantité de ville du monde et
peut-être même dans certaines vœux
encore dans certaines rues parisiennes
peut-être pas mais en tout cas dans
certaines rues et puis sur ce fond de
long au Moyen-Âge qui peut donc aller
pratiquement jusqu'à aujourd'hui voir
jusqu'à demain les choses se compliquent
des ruptures successives dont
l'automobile est évidemment une rupture
majeure alors j'avais dans un premier
temps puisqu'on a un troisième chapitre
qui porte sur les ruptures je voulais
mettre l'automobile dans ce chapitre
mais ça a amené à traiter l'automobile
d'avoir la Révolution française qui
était un peu compliqué pour le lecteur
donc nous avons ouvert la dernière
partie par l'automobile étant entendu
que cette automobile enfin le moment où
l'automobile produit des effets sociaux
de toute nature et
plus tard oui mais je reviens à ma
question on avait une ville qui était
pour le meilleur et pour le pire une
ville de la sociabilité et d'ailleurs
finalement j'ai appris ça en vous disant
mais le fait que les maisons soient
fermées sur la rue que les immeubles
soient fermés je parle pas de digicode
mais le simple fait que les immeubles
soient fermés ou que les tavernes soient
fermés est une invention assez récente
finalement donc il y avait il y a une
époque dans lequel le public est le
privé sont confondus et dans lequel la
rue et le lieu de l'échange
sous réserve d'un certain nombre de de
particularisme sociaux mais c'est quand
même le lieu de l'échanger et puis quand
même depuis on a on avait l'impression
jusqu'à une date récente on va y revenir
que notamment l'éruption de l'automobile
avait transformé la ville et laver
déshumaniser
j'ai repris une photo de Shanghai outre
les couloirs dont nous avons l'habitude
de trottinette vélo automobile on ajoute
à l'achat dans la photo que j'ai trouvé
à Shanghai un couloir pour les Joker et
à Canton il y a des couloirs pour les
personnes qui marchent mais qui marche
avec le Riva iPhone qui par conséquent
sont un rythme différent donc la rue qui
était ce lieu creuset ce lieu de la
rencontre ce lieu pour le meilleur et
pour le pire comme vous le disiez
et traversé par des tensions aujourd'hui
qui l'amène à être un lieu de séparation
où chacun doit trouver son espace et
vivre sa vie ça va faire écho à la
conversation qu'on va avoir bientôt avec
Daniel Cohen mais alors il y a tout de
même j'ai l'impression quand vous lisant
qu'il y a une réaction récente que
depuis très peu de temps à travers
la récréation d'espaces verts la
piétonnisation de Paris on a essayé de
réagir à cette déshumanisation de la
capitale et et des villes en général et
de réinventer une sociabilité qui avait
disparu ça se voit presque même de
manière inattendue dans les
manifestations parce que vous décrivez
comment les manifestations on est passé
de la rue comme lieu de l'insurrection
et de la révolution au lieu de la
manifestation pépère qu'on a bien connu
de la Bastia République c'est moi qui
c'est moi qui tout à coup les Black
Blocs les gilets jaunes on retrouve une
espèce de de de de d'effervescence de la
rue qui a disparu donc il y a une
réaction à la déshumanisation la rue est
indéniablement aujourd'hui le lieu d'une
tension entre ce phénomène de
séparation qui peut nous amener au gâté
de Community qui sont une mort de la rue
pour comprendre ce que disait dans un
autre contexte de Corbusier de Community
je dis ça pour ceux qui nous écoutent ce
sont ces communautés fermées aux
États-Unis ce sont des ensembles de gens
qui habitent ensemble mais derrière des
des des des parois pour protéger et
garder et et puis toutes ces
réappropriations de la rue alors qu'ils
passent par tous les exemples que vous
avez donné mais que l'on trouve
également dans le domaine de l'art avec
le street art voir l'ensemble des termes
qui sont des termes anglo-saxons
construits sur Street street food Street
street dance
et c'est le lieu d'une tension et d'une
contradiction qui n'est pas totalement
résolue à la date où nous parlons ça
d'ailleurs on voit d'ailleurs que ça
suscite cette transformation des villes
suscite des réactions on le voit à Paris
avec
[Musique]
un certain nombre de slogans contre la
désagrégation de la capitale on sent que
le de la même manière on va le voir que
le monde numérique suscite des
inquiétudes la transformation des villes
inquiète ses habitants qui sentent
confusément que quelque chose est en
train de disparaître malgré les efforts
pour faire renaître la sociabilité alors
sociabilité mais par exemple c'est très
intéressant de voir comment
les rues piétonnières qui nous
apparaissent comme
la sociabilité réintroduite au cœur de
la ville en même temps pour ces
quantités de problèmes emprunts qui ont
le sentiment que par la rue piétonnière
la ville leur échappe puisqu'elle
devient le lieu de ceux qui viennent y
boire du bon vin oui goûter de bons
petits plats de toute de toute nature
c'est aussi le lieu d'une mondialisation
culinaire mais qui devient invivable au
quotidien donc
je le répète tension et contradiction
tension et contradictions histoire de la
rue de l'Antiquité à nos jours mais je
pense que en tout cas si on en croit
l'ouvrage de Daniel Cohen Homo Numericus
si on adhère à la marche de la société
qui nous décrit ce que nous connaissons
en matière de déshumanisation n'est rien
à côté de ce qui nous attend
donc Daniel vous êtes économistes mais
là vous sortez de votre discipline et à
partir d'un certain nombre d'éléments
d'ailleurs une série de d'observation
toute très intéressante vous vous
décrivez un monde qui est en train de se
construire je le disais qu'il n'est pas
rassurant d'abord c'est un monde je vais
faire la liste des diagn d'abord c'est
un monde qui nous abrutit on est en
train de devenir vous reprenez
l'expression d'un ouvrage d'un autre
auteur des crétins numériques
oui il y a une forme de il y a une forme
de crétinisation qui qui se produit
puisque le numérique est fait pour nous
rendre addictif assez assez produite
donc quand on regarde sur son portable
des news on cherche pas une news en
particulier on se crole comme ça un peu
comme un écureuil dans sa dans sa cage
même savoir ce qu'on cherche sans savoir
ce qu'on a retenu donc oui il y a un
phénomène d'abêtissement on peut y voir
le prolongement par d'autres moyens de
ce que la télévision avait produit en
son temps ça ne vient pas toute armée en
dehors du monde la télévision déjà avait
été si on suit un sociologue qui
s'appelle Robert Putnam ça avait été le
point de départ d'une individualisation
du monde il raconte dans un livre
magnifique qui s'appelle bowling long
dans lequel il explique on va faire du
bowling tout seul aux États-Unis alors
qu'avant on était toujours dans un club
il dit les clubs de bowling ont commencé
à disparaître comme les clubs de bridge
comme les associations parents d'élèves
à peu près en même en même temps que la
télévision s'est imposée parce qu'elle a
individualisé nos destins on peut voir
une forme de continuation de ça par
d'autres le lien mais c'est beaucoup
d'accord alors deuxième deuxième élément
de votre diagnostic c'est un monde de
surveillance généralisée alors le propre
de l'intelligence artificielle en
réalité c'est ça dont on parle et on en
est que au tout début c'est d'avoir la
possibilité par qui de droit c'est fait
partie de la question d'avoir une
information très précise rigoureuse sur
les 8 milliards d'humains que compte
désormais depuis 15 ans notre notre
planète il y a aucune aucun obstacle
technique à tout savoir de chacun de ces
8 milliards où ils sont où ils habitent
qu'est-ce qu'ils font leur préférence
donc il y a quelque chose évidemment
dewélien dans cette dans cette dimension
et là au fait ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le vis-à-vis entre les deux
sociologue encore un autre Américain qui
s'appelle Daniel Bel qui parlait des
contradictions culturelles du
capitalisme et il disait le capitalisme
c'est d'un côté l'ordre de la de la
production qui est rigoureux qui est
dans l'abstinence il faut oublier toute
idée de désir et puis lors de la
consommation c'est exactement
pour faire la [__] il faut être dans
la débauche dans la luxe c'est cette
contradiction qui dit-il explique
pourquoi culturellement et pas
économiquement c'est un petit clin
d'oeil aux contradictions économiques de
Marx le capitalisme est instable il est
sur deux registres à la fois bien là
encore je veux pas m'obliger à mettre de
la continuité partout mais on peut y
voir la continuation de cette
contradiction d'un côté on est surveillé
rigoureusement dans tous les éléments de
votre désir pour être dirigé vers ce
qu'il est optimal que vous soyez en
mesure de consommer et de l'autre on
vous avait dit complètement donc c'est
cet être double qui marque encore une
fois un cran de plus dans une histoire
plus longue peut-être qui remonte voilà
au début mais fort accélération alors
troisième élément c'est la polarisation
c'est-à-dire vous expliquer que loin
d'être le lieu du forum du de la du
débat généralisé de l'échange des idées
le monde numérique produit exactement
l'inverse c'est-à-dire chacun se
renferme dans sa communauté d'idées et
d'opinions et plus et ce radicalise
polarisation éradicalisation alors
en effet en réalité c'est ça le point de
départ du livre j'avais écrit un livre
avec des politologues qui s'appelaient
les origines du populisme dans lequel on
essayait de faire la source du populisme
contemporain et là on le retrouve
s'exprimer dans la dans la civilisation
numérique qui est en train de
s'installer c'est-à-dire un formidable
écart entre les attentes que le
numérique en ses débuts a fait naître
Wikipédia la possibilité de créer
peut-être moi j'ai cru au tout début
comme Internet est apparu dans les
années 90 j'ai pensé que ça allait
donner au fond le substrat d'une société
civile planétaire qui allait être la
contrepartie de la mondialisation
économique on allait la mondialisation
économique et il y a besoin en phase de
contre-pouvoirs d'une société civile qui
est capable de s'organiser face au flux
économique et donc je voyais avec
enthousiasme une intelligence collective
nette dans les années 90 et il y a ça un
peu en partie il y a des mouvements
planétaires mis tout black live matters
qui qui crée au fond les éléments de ce
qui pouvait être attendu mais on voit en
même temps est parallèlement et
contradictoirement et de manière plus
forte exactement le contraire se produit
voir apparaître que en effet sur les
réseaux sociaux une conversation
philosophique une conversation
scientifique est devenue tout à fait
impossible on ne peut pas discuter sur
Internet on ne peut pas introduire de la
subtilité de la contradiction sans être
immédiatement jeté au pylori de la
pensée X ou Y donc c'est l'immense
déception de cette société numérique
elle est faite pour permettre de
communiquer et c'est le contraire c'est
de la postérité c'est de la fake news et
font tout le contraire de ce qu'on
attendait au départ alors si je fais la
somme de ces effets on arrive au thème
de cette de cette émission c'est
vraiment ce que vous décrivez en tout
cas le risque principal qui pèse sur
nous c'est le risque de la déliaison
c'est le risque de la fin de la
sociabilité d'ailleurs Vous faites
l'éloge des institutions qui permettait
de tenir ensemble à la fin et la
contradiction que vous évoquez
c'est-à-dire d'un côté une société et de
l'autre une société d'individus vous
disait ce qui fait que tout ça tient
c'est les institutions et vous
prophétisez la fin de ces institutions
et avec elle la fin de la possibilité de
vivre ensemble non je prophétise pas la
fin des institutions au contraire je
fais leur éloge à la fin mais en effet
si on essaie de comprendre d'où vient
cette bifurcation entre un monde attendu
on puisse en effet discuter comme on le
fait avec des collègues étrangers enfin
il y a beaucoup de choses qui marchent
bien sous la sous ce qui ne marche pas
bien quand on essaye de comprendre quand
j'essaye de comprendre qu'est-ce qui ne
va pas je pense qu'en effet cette
question des institutions est très
importante et là le numérique n'en est
pas la cause il est l'amplificateur mais
on peut situer au fond dans ce dans
cette espèce de partie de ping-pong qui
sait jouer entre les années 60 et les
années 80 la cause de toutes ces
ambiguïtés les années 60 c'est la
contre-culture des années 60 c'est la
critique de la verticalité du monde
même l'héritage de peut-être de la
société agraire pré-industrielle une
verticalité qu'on trouve dans tous les
domaines de la société le Mandarina dans
les dans les universités le patriarcat
dans les familles et puis dans l'ordre
de la production ce dont parlait Daniel
belge il y a quelque chose de
parfaitement vertical avec des patrons
des non libertaire et donc il y a une
critique de cette verticalité du monde
qui est la première brique de cette
société numérique puisque les premiers
pionniers dans les années 70 ont pensé
qu'ils allaient donner à cette
aspiration à l'horizontalité des
relations sociales les moyens de
s'exprimer mais vient dans les années 80
la contre-révolution conservatrice
Madame Thatcher Regan qui elle au fond
réinterprète la révolution culturelle
des années 60 en disant ok plus de
verticalité c'est simple ça sera un
monde de mise en compétition générale et
donc on démantèle ces grands groupes
industriels et leur verticalité pour y
substituer un rapport de mise en
compétition entre le donneur d'ordre et
le sous-traitant madame Sacha disait la
société je ne sais pas ce que ça veut
dire pour elle ce sont des individus qui
s'allient et qui s'alliance et bien le
mont numérique il est l'héritier de ça
il a une grammaire à la fois
anti-système fonce on peut entendre
l'écho des lacs de la contre-culture des
années 60 ou aucune autorité révélée ne
peut en surplomb expliquer X ou Y à la
société mais aussi profondément
héritier de cette contre-révolution
conservatrice dans lequel on va
supprimer les institutions qui
existaient avant n'ont pas pour
remplacer les remplacer par d'autres
mais pas il substituer une mise en
compétition et bien le monde du
numérique c'est ça on est antisysté
aucune figure de l'autorité ne peut se
faire entendre de droit bon très bien et
puis c'est une formidable mise en
compétition des individus qui pour se
faire entendre doivent parler plus haut
que les autres inventer une nouvelle
syntaxe de l'horreur de la détestation
de l'horreur et c'est ce cas-là qui
explique il est désocialisation il est
l'enfant monstrueux de l'élan liberté et
du libéralisme
parce que est-ce que c'est pas
simplement une question de d'échelle de
temps est-ce qu'on va pas arriver à
réguler quelque chose qui au fond
produit par ailleurs un fantastique et
long à la fois de liberté d'accès à la
d'accès au savoir
d'échanges de liberté les fonds soient
rien des femmes iraniennes aujourd'hui
si ce monde n'était pas là est-ce que
c'est pas simplement qui va nous falloir
du temps pour réguler cet univers oui
d'abord encore une fois c'était long
libertaire pour le dire comme ça il est
là dans les réseaux sociaux meetub black
climater la révolte des femmes
iraniennes la révolution arabe tout ça
bien sûr se saisit de ce que permet de
de produire cette révolution numérique
donc il y a cette aspiration et elle est
elle est très forte elle est très bien
le problème c'est que cette aspiration
elle n'arrive pas à partir de la
détestation ou de la critique d'un monde
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire le
meilleur évidemment dans les exemples
qu'on donne elle n'arrive pas à donner
les moyens d'en reconstruire un autre
parce que elle n'est pas faite pour ça
donc même sur le la question du
réchauffement climatique il y a une
protestation contre l'inaction des
gouvernements mais ce n'est pas avec une
boucle WhatsApp qu'on peut imaginer une
société désirable sobre en énergie c'est
il faut des il faut des entreprises il
faut des savants faut des syndicats il
faut des partis politiques donc c'est
quelque chose de très profond et je ne
vois pas ça disparaître je souhaite
bonne chance aux parties pour se
reconstituer dans leur mission
historique mais ça va être très
difficile de même les entreprises fixer
un lieu dans lequel il y avait des
tensions des syndicats il y avait des
contradictions tout ça vole en éclat
donc c'est très dur d'imaginer ce qui
peut être construit mais je crois le
message c'est sans institution pour
fixer un cadre à l'intérieur desquels
vous pouvez être en désaccord tout en
étant en accord sur quelque chose au
dessus une recherche d'une vérité
scientifique vous n'y arriverez pas on
va poursuivre cette conversation avec un
lecteur car après tout le bonheur des
livres c'est d'abord le plaisir des
lecteurs et ce lecteur c'est Martin et
il a une question à poser à Daniel Cohen
Martin on vous écoute
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Martin j'ai 24 ans
je suis juriste en protection des
données et je me considère aujourd'hui
comme un lecteur plutôt régulier
j'essaye de lire la presse tous les
jours si c'est le plus de livres
possibles
je suis passionné d'économie et de droit
et le dernier livre que j'ai lu et qui
m'a marqué c'est ce qui s'appelle
l'entreprise altruiste disa get et
Laurent marbacher ce livre décrit le
concept du coup un nouveau concept
d'entreprise dans une entreprise
altruiste
la question que j'aimerais poser à
monsieur Cohen après la lecture de son
livre c'est pensez-vous aujourd'hui que
les entreprises de nouvelles
technologies les entreprises innovantes
doivent être éthiques sur le plan moral
sur le plan social sur le plan
écologique pour pouvoir continuer
croître et à se développer
alors Daniel est-ce que les entreprises
doivent être ils peuvent être et les
entreprises numériques peuvent être
éthiques donc elles doivent l'être
évidemment elles doivent être éthiques
parce que il faut il faut introduire de
nouvelles manières de penser les
relations interpersonnelles au sein même
de l'entreprise mais le point le plus
important à mon avis pour faire le lien
avec ce avec ce livre c'est que c'est
très facile d'être éthique dans le monde
actuel parce que au fond les entreprises
sont de plus en plus les entreprises de
haute technologie notamment de plus en
plus homogènes socialement c'était
hétérogénéité qu'on trouvait dans les
dans les usines des années 50-60 a
disparu donc on a des des entreprises
des bureaux d'études des bureaux
d'ingénieurs des gens où en font on se
retrouve entre soi ou cette promesse
d'horizontalité qui vient des années 60
est accomplie tout le monde se tutoie
dans une boîte aujourd'hui parce que
tout le monde se ressemble il y a des
différences d'âge et puis c'est tout
donc moi ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est de s'assurer que cette exigence
que les entreprises tout en haut de la
chaîne de valeur peuvent s'imposer
elles-mêmes percolent bien sur
l'ensemble de la société donc j'ai et de
leur sous-traitants et de leur
sous-traitants et donc j'ai une idée
simple en position vraiment très simple
presque stupide c'est de dire pour
bénéficier de la commande publique il
faut une notation sociale triple A c'est
voilà vous êtes étude vous êtes soucieux
de l'environnement mais il faut vous
sous-traitants aussi soit triple ce qui
veut dire que les sous-traitants des
sous-traitants doivent être aussi triple
et donc retrouver cette manière de
diffuser dans la société des choses qui
aujourd'hui sont totalement éclatées je
suis heureux d'entendre que vous faites
des propositions c'est un cataplasme à
l'inquiétude que votre diagnostic
génère alors cette émission s'achève
mais évidemment on aimerait avoir plus
d'auteurs on peut pas tous les inviter
mais on peut parler des livres qu'on a
aimé et munir ce qui nous écoute de
quelques qui nous suivent de quelques
nourritures supplémentaires donc je vais
vous demander à chacun quel est votre
livre coup de coeur en sachant que la
tension c'est satisfait ou remboursé il
faut que ce soit vraiment un livre dont
ceux qui nous suivent se disent waouh
c'était celui-là qu'il fallait que je le
dise on va commencer par vous Daniel
Cohen
du coup le c'est venu dans le cours de
cette discussion je recommanderais ce
livre de Putnam qui s'appelle bowling je
crois il a été traduit en français j'ai
pas la traduction mais c'est un livre
extraordinaire je pense un des plus
grands livres de sociologie américaine
des 20 dernières années dans lequel il
refait tout le parcours qui nous amène à
cette individualisation croissante donc
il donne un rôle très important à la
télévision mais pas seulement il
explique comment la mairie qui au début
des années 60 avait toutes les
caractéristiques d'une société fortement
communautarisée au bon sens du terme
c'est chacun appartenait à une église à
une association parents d'élèves etc
s'est retrouvé un agrégat de gens seuls
Daniel tartaclocci quel est le livre
dans le prolongement de la discussion et
pour nous inquiéter un peu plus comment
diriger sans compromis
Jérémy Rubinstein
terreur et séduction histoire de la
guerre histoire de la doctrine de la
guerre révolutionnaire par quoi il faut
comprendre la doctrine contre
révolutionnaire alors ça nous emmène
Indochine autochenaire d'Amérique latine
en passant par la guerre d'Algérie ça
fait très peur mais il vaut mieux être
au courant bon alors moi j'espère je
vais vous ragaillère dire un peu parce
que au bonheur des livres nous avons
choisi Cynthia osic antiquité c'est une
écrivain qui doit maintenant avoir une
écrivaine qui a 94 ans qui est une
grande une grande écrivain de la
littérature juive américaine
l'équivalent enfin de Philippe rot mais
beaucoup moins connu que lui en très
connu aux États-Unis et qui écrit peu
mais qui écrit vraiment chaque livre est
un bijou je suis sûr que ça va vous
intéresser je vous l'offre et puisqu'on
parle de Philippe Roth grand grand
écrivain américain qui aurait dû avoir
le Nobel mais qui n'a pas eu
et on s'habille au graphie vient de
paraître et alors on voit ça ça nous
rassure parce qu'on voit qu'on peut être
anxieux pessimiste dépressif ce qui
était son cas et en même temps avoir une
vie notamment une vie sentimentale très
très riche donc on peut sortir de cette
émission pessimiste
en même temps ne pas cesser de goûter la
vie je suis sûr que ça intéressera
Daniel c'est biographie interdites c'est
ça c'est celle qui ne devait pas sortir
exactement
sans aucun rapport Aragon le prince des
poètes du 20e siècle on a tous en tête
on a qu'on connaît tous les poèmes
d'Aragon celui qui croyait aussi elle
est celui qui n'y croyait pas ce sont
ces derniers poèmes qui paraissent en
poche les poèmes de l'extrême maturité
et qui sont beaucoup moins connus et
cependant magnifique j'aurais très envie
de le garder pour moi mais je suis sûr
que ça va plaire à Daniel darfakowski
compte tenu son engagement et enfin
chaque semaine on fait
on parle d'une bande dessinée là c'est
un texte de jeunesse de dalmodovar
illustré par Manara Manara c'est le
grand dessinateur érotique italien
vivant en France donc ce livre est quand
même lisible par chacun mais comme il
est une incitation non pas à la débauche
enfin je voudrais pas passer pour un
corrupteur donc celui-là je me le garde
je ne l'offre aucun d'entre vous et
c'est seulement par souci de la vertu
voilà cette émission est terminée merci
[Musique]